thank you very much christina good
morning good afternoon good evening um
thank you everybody for joining this
webinar today
um
my name is bill kingston i'm a solutions
architect at f5
here at f5 i spend a lot of time helping
customers and our community adopt nginx
and f5 technology
from looking at many environments and
topologies we see many patterns in
modernization microservices and cloud
native technologies
so today i'm going to speak primarily
about the fundamentals of microservices
now i know this is quite a broad topic
so i'll do my very best to go through
some of the most popular
trends and technologies that we do see
when speaking to the community and to
our customers
there are so many reasons why companies
would shift from a more traditional
monolithic architecture to a more
cloud-native microservices-based
architecture
it could be to reduce costs it could be
to avoid single points of failure it
could be to shorten the the application
development cycle in a devops
environment perhaps but there are so
many reasons why
so i will explain at a very high level
some of the technologies that we do see
in some of the most popular applications
in the world today
i will briefly describe what a modern
app is
why some companies should modernize why
devops is important
of course we cannot talk about
microservices if without mentioning
things like containers things like
kubernetes we'll spend a little bit of
time going through what an ingress
controller is
service mesh we will also talk about
which is a very hot topic right now also
do you need one what is it
are you ready for one perhaps
and finally
it's important to understand why
production grade
applications and solutions can save you
time
it can simplify your architecture and
reduce costs so let's get started
so this
slide in particular here is
is a maturity model that represents
different stages where companies tend to
sit
the first stage being a monolith or
traditional application
and this is usually an application that
is built
as a single unit
a good example of this would be
a very simple application that has a
database
a client-side user interface
html pages for example
and a server-side application that's a
php application
to make any alterations to this system
a developer may need to build and deploy
an updated version of the server side
application which can be very slow
it's very difficult to scale
and overall making one change to the
application might require a big bang
release
the next stage is what we like to call
hybrid which is essentially a mix and
match you know you have some modern
components and you have some traditional
components
but most customers i've spoken with that
are
fall within this umbrella because
obviously
we have some modern applications but
traditional applications they're not
going away anytime soon
so let's say for example you you want to
create some microservices-based
functionality but the core of the
application is still the monitor
for example maybe you have created an
authentication service
using modern technologies
and a mobile application might be a good
example of a hybrid
application
and in front of you it looks like a very
modern app but behind the scenes it
might be a traditional app with old
technology doing the bits and pieces
and then we get to the next stage what
we call microservices
this is modern modern application
usually built from the ground up as
multiple isolated services that are
stitched together
usually it's a single application
perhaps it's born in the cloud
but they are most definitely developed
deployed and tested with a very
sophisticated cicd pipeline
there's usually automated testing and
release orchestration maybe they're in
kubernetes
but usually these are very specific
digital services maybe something
specific to your industry or business
units
so as i mentioned most of the companies
that i've worked with have fallen into
the hybrid
buckets and monolithic i suppose
we're seeing more and more companies
adopt a hybrid model where they're
trying to transition to more modern
environment
but microservices is the ideal state
that many companies shoot for
so here is an example of a monolith
this is a taxi application
and as you can see we have
components for payments trip management
building and so on and so forth
it's most likely a very large chunk of
code with many components
but here it's a single unit it might
have a single shared database releases
are very slow perhaps a waterfall
methodology
but because all of the components of the
application are linked together if you
wanted to make an update to one
component you might have to bring down
the entire application
releases are very slow maybe you're
releasing a new update every six months
as a big bang release
but services are very tightly coupled
they're very dependent on each other and
communication between each of these
services is done using synchronous
method calls
so
when you flip this monolith on its head
a little bit
we've separated these components
we have we now have smaller pieces of
code per service
and maybe they're connected via apis you
can see the rest api logo here
so now we have a micro services
environment where each microservice runs
its own process
these may be deployed in containers or
pods in kubernetes
and they all communicate with each other
using a mechanism such as a rest api
but the idea to simplify is one
microservice for each function
this is not going to happen in a single
step it's
it could be very expensive very risky
and you don't want to re-architect your
entire application in one go so this is
going to take time there is a pattern
known as the strangler pattern that you
may be familiar with the idea is that
you add
small pieces of functionality in
microservice microservices and repeat
the process
for example the authentication service i
mentioned
earlier but it's very important you
adopt a devops mentality here so having
proper source control having automation
having the teams organized around
service ownership
but
services in a microservices environment
they should all work together as loosely
coupled rather than tightly coupled
services
and each service should have one job and
that should do that job very well
they're isolated
so each micro service might have its own
data so it can evolve and scale
by itself
and if you needed to update the
application you can just update that
specific microservice
so
microservices the idea is
to take an application
and
take that application and take specific
components and
compose them into loosely coupled and
independently deployed services
usually microservices are very
maintainable and testable they're
usually smaller self-contained loosely
coupled
we're using apis of course modern
applications and oftentimes need an api
and this could be message brokers or
event streamers also so
it's possible that each microservice
might have its own language maybe have
one microservice deployed in java and
another microservice deployed in php
but usually they're deployed around
business capabilities
so separating services to have a
specific capabilities
and obviously
having teams organized so that you have
specific teams managing specific
microservices can definitely help
but
coming from f5 and nginx
proxying solutions for these
environments are changing in that
a traditional load balancer
might now be known as an api gateway or
an ingress controller in kubernetes or
perhaps using a service mesh
so this is why we hear terms like api
management kubernetes and service mesh
solutions like istio
so there are many different areas of
change in the migration from analytic to
microservices we're moving to apis we're
moving to the cloud perhaps we're moving
to containers
more lightweight protocols like a
restful api
release cycles are changing if you're if
you're
within a devops environment you might be
releasing multiple times per day
and obviously the bigger the application
gets the longer
and more frequently the releases get
as you move to microservices we're
releasing multiple times per day you can
have development of different
microservices happen in parallel which
is a huge advantage
which brings me to collaboration across
teams teams are managed differently
we're moving to a devops culture where
devops teams are more involved with the
entire release process we have
automation
and you can use many different
programming languages as your of your
choosing
just to take a little step back here and
focus a little bit on some of the key
trends we're seeing within the
microservices landscape
nothing should be too surprising here
but i just wanted to share our
perspective what we are seeing in the
enterprises
organizations are modernizing at a rapid
pace
um about three quarters of enterprise
prices from our state of application
services survey
reported that they're
that
our customers are modernizing internal
or customer facing applications with
apis and containers as the primary
method giving their ability to combine
capabilities with modern and traditional
components
devops is on the rise
it's obviously devops is very critical
to agility and help and things like
automation can
can speed things up and you might might
be familiar with automation tools for
infrastructure as well rather than
applications and tools like terraform
you know you can set up and manage your
infrastructure via apis like terraform
so just to mention kubernetes very
briefly as kubernetes
adoption continues to increase um at
nginx we're closely tracking the
kubernetes and cloud native journeys and
we ask our community oftentimes a number
of questions around kubernetes adoption
and we did so last year and 35
of our community uh said that they were
using kubernetes in production
another 35 said they were actively
exploring kubernetes and 30
said that they they haven't adopted
kubernetes yet
so when asked
when do you plan to implement kubernetes
72
reported plans to put kubernetes into
production within the next 12 months
so yeah that's
kubernetes adoption is
is continues to accelerate it's a common
strategy in modern app initiatives but
it's definitely a very important part of
that microservices journal
now let's take another step back
and focus a little bit on the
microservices technologies
so
containers
most of the most important technologies
that allow microservices at scale
is the is the container
why are containers so popular well
compared to virtual machines
containers are quick to build they're
small
which means that they can be stored
transported over to a network over
another network
they're very well defined they can run
anywhere and they're stateless as well
most of the time
so containers are a key component of
that microservices journey and they are
a solution to the problem of how to get
software to run reliably
in one infrastructure and another
so put simply
a container consists of
an entire
runtime environment so an application
with dependencies
libraries other binaries and all
configuration files that are needed
bundled into one package
by containerizing this application and
its dependencies
all of the os distributions and
infrastructure
is abstracted away
so if you look at a virtual machine and
traditionally when using a virtual
machine for applications
you're taking an entire
operating system as well as the
application so you might have a physical
server
that runs three virtual machines you
have a hypervisor and
multiple operating systems running for
each for
each virtual machine
so
that's heavy and by contrast a server
running
containerized applications with docker
for example
you have a single operating system
and each container shares that operating
system kernel from the machine
so that means the containers are much
more lightweight and they use far fewer
resources than virtual machines
so this is the foundation
for bringing portability to
microservices applications
as well as some legacy applications of
course
it is possible to put legacy
applications into a container obviously
but the difference obviously comes down
to the size of the applications
dependencies and so on and so forth
but there isn't an analogy known as
catholic versus pets that you might be
familiar with and the idea is that in
the old way of doing things we treated
our servers like like pets
for example a mail server
you might have a mail server downstairs
in the server room
that server goes down
it's all hands on deck ceo can't get
their email and it's a big problem
in the new way of doing things with
microservices
it's more like cattle than a herd you
know if a service goes down
you just replace this there and then you
just spin up another container
and it's not really a big deal
and the kubernetes for example you scale
your applications horizontally if a
container completes its job you just
destroy it
and when they complete the job
you can either destroy it or you can
you can reduce the size of it also so
it's a very dynamic environment it's
much different
now this isn't a kubernetes course
so i'll do my very best to explain this
at a very high level
kubernetes is the orchestrator
for containers
it's the magic that makes it all
happen so when it comes to kubernetes
there are multiple components
first of all there are multiple nodes
you would have a kubernetes master node
you will have kubernetes worker nodes
and you would have an internal network
you might have an ingress controller
you might have a load balancer
so the master node is
will contain the key kubernetes
components
your worker nodes will contain
the containers
of your applications
each of these interacts via an internal
kubernetes pod network
and of course you might have an ingress
controller bringing traffic in this is
your layer 72
but the idea is kubernetes
is all about container orchestration
it's about managing and coordinating the
life cycle of containers especially in
large
dynamic environments software teams use
tools like kubernetes to control and
automate many tasks some examples could
be
provisioning containers deploying
containers
scaling your containers
horizontally or or downwards
moving containers from one node to
another
exposing containers to the outside world
load balancing monitoring containers the
list goes on and on
what the idea is that
the kubernetes cluster is the management
of the control plane for your containers
running inside of the cluster
more on the ingress controller later
now there are absolutely some drawbacks
when implementing a modern microservices
architecture
there are so many changes happening in
this environment
for example you might have
a traditional application might have
function calls that are very easy
to configure and then everything makes
sense whereas now with a microservices
application running in kubernetes for
example
communication between your services
is much more complicated
there are no network calls rather than
function calls
debugging is very difficult because it's
not just one application on a single
machine anymore it could be an
application spread across multiple
machines
that application might have multiple
microservices and with it within each
microservice it has its own set of logs
tracing and the source of finding a
problem can be very difficult
it comes to testing
it might be easier to unit test with
microservices to test the functionality
of our component whereas integration
testing meaning testing the entire
application is more difficult because
the components are now distributed so
developers cannot test an entire system
from their individual machines anymore
we are updating the application a lot
more yes that's a good thing
but you need to spend time automating
and
learning how to roll back their issues
if you're adopting a devops mentality
if you're writing an ansible playbook or
a chef script for an automation task you
have to write another for rolling back
if there are issues that takes time
if a microservice has its own api
they need to be consistent
if you're updating the api of one
microservice
the the other microservices need to be
in sync and understand the new api
version
one thing that i don't have mentioned
here i should mention is that
what we're seeing more and more is that
companies are adopting a multi-cloud
strategy
when it comes when they're deploying
their microservices
so they might be deploying application
services across
multiple clouds like aws zero or
gcp
some they might have some on-prem
so when different microservices are
spread across across multiple
different clouds it can be very
difficult to keep track so all of these
points here
relate to that
now here's an example of
of an environment that we often see and
most some of the most popular
applications we see have something
similar to this
now it's important to note that
every environment is different but
this the flow was oftentimes very
similar
so you have multiple components many
teams
looking after each of those individual
components
you have the application teams looking
after the application the devops teams
ensuring that updates are happening in
the ci servers working you have all your
automation scripts you might have a
security team looking after the web
application firewall
whether the infrastructure or networking
team looking after
everything else networking with it
maybe you're using open source solutions
or enterprise solutions
if you're using an nginx ingress
controller or fight big-ip for security
perhaps you're using monitoring tools
like grafana prometheus
authentication tools like octa key club
different security products automation
tools like ansible devops tools like
gitlab the list this list goes on and on
but this is the flow that we often see
you have your code repository you have
your csv pipeline you're deploying the
application
within containers to a kubernetes
environment and you have external tools
for monitoring for security for logging
and so on and so forth
what i'm trying to say here is that this
is the data plane
the data plane
is
is there to control and monitor how
traffic is sent to and routed within
their microservices application so this
is
probably the most important point we
depend on the data plane
kubernetes and microservices are often
used hand in hand almost synonymous
these days i guess
kubernetes has emerged as the favored
container orchestration platform
so it is the gold standard for modern
container-based microservices
but the data plane which is your traffic
flow to your applications handles all
traffic from the
client
to
the application container
and that includes load balancing
proxying security analytics open tracing
all those things are very important and
usually there are specific teams looking
after specific areas within that flow
developers infrastructure engineers
security teams operations and so on and
so forth
so very briefly some of the challenges
and concerns that we
we've seen
we asked customers recently what are
your biggest concerns about around
kubernetes
we've got a multitude of answers ranging
from very small details to very broad
concerns about configuration
learning curve was obviously
very popular
how you handle persistent data in a
kubernetes cluster was another
very popular point that was made
but the four big ones
were knowledge complexity security and
scalability
so knowledge the biggest concern was
not being able to understand the
technology and how it works
and that makes sense because
kubernetes networking is hard kubernetes
security is higher
um
[Music]
there's a pretty steep learning curve
when it comes to someone who's new to
kubernetes you have to understand
container networking
it's a completely different language
so
that leads me into complexity it's not
even when kubernetes
is deployed in its out-of-the-box form
without management tools like openshift
or tensor
kubernetes is pretty well documented but
the networking
is completely different than those that
came before that
containers are still relatively new
technology
and
other things like certificate management
complications and security is then the
next point
to be honest kubernetes when it's
deployed out of the box basically has no
security turned on
which is quite a risk
you know enterprises
looking to learn kubernetes as they
deploy applications is probably one of
the main reasons why things take time
why things are slow in adoption
i say security doesn't come out of the
box i mean
if you're deploying applications in
kubernetes with no web application
firewall you might start exposing
applications
um
directly with no proxy and that's that
can be that can be a security risk
and finally scalability
now this is kind of ironic because
the idea is that you have a kubernetes
cluster and you can scale
your applications or your pods at will
but
what we mean by scalability here is that
because kubernetes is so complex
a lot of the concerns are around the
platform scaling the platform
it's very challenging to operate
a kubernetes cluster at scale you know
if you have multiple nodes multiple pods
within each node and they're
continuously scaling
you need to have resources for that you
need to have a team looking after
the resource configuration of kubernetes
and it can be quite complex and it does
become a concern
okay so the ingress
controller
now as with microservices containers
have really
become very popular because they do
provide a massive benefit to the
application development process they're
very dependable they scale
they provide a nice isolation layer
and many microservices applications rely
on on this technology to operate in
kubernetes
so traffic management into and within
kubernetes
is often handled by a load balancer
what we call an ingress controller
an ingress controller is responsible for
bringing traffic into your kubernetes
cluster think of it as an nginx proxy
for now it's configured a little
differently to an nginx proxy
but
it's essentially an enginex load
balancer sitting
in front of kubernetes so it's all it's
a layer 7 http primarily
and it brings traffic in deals with
north south traffic
everything you would use nginx for like
tls termination load balancing and much
much more and that that is where
you would use nginx
uses something called an ingress
resource to configure itself
and it does a lot of things than just
load balancing obviously it can scale
like like other containers do you can
monitor the the status of your pods and
do health checks and tls termination and
so on and so forth but
it's it's essentially your layer 7 load
balancer that brings external traffic
into your cluster
it's important to note
that there may also be
another load balancer
in front of the ingest controller
and this could be a dns load balancer it
could be a cloud
a tcp load balancer perhaps
every environment is different of course
it could be a big ip if it's on-prem
so usually you have your dns service
that routes traffic to and ingress and
then your ingress does all of the
application traffic
now one struggle that we're often seeing
in companies adopt microservices within
kubernetes in a dynamic environment is
the infrastructure
scaling the infrastructure
another problem is that the app the
actual teams the application teams
it's getting very complicated for them
to operate
because they're designing the entire
environment around application
complexity
so
web application firewall policies
routing rules rate limiting api
management and so on and so forth
the teams do get complicated when
organizing around these complexities
i myself have
more of an application slash devops
background it used to be a developer
but i'm very familiar with deploying
applications writing applications and
getting them ready for production but
what i'm seeing a lot more
is the complexity around networking and
security when you start deploying these
applications into the nets
you have ip tables and security policies
and all these things
application teams are starting to feel
more like infrastructure teams and
security teams
are starting to feel like more like
application teams when getting stuck in
the kubernetes
so service mesh very briefly if we
return to our distributed microservices
application here
the
ingress controller
is responsible for controlling traffic
coming into the application
and this is known as north south traffic
it has no visibility
or control over traffic flowing
within the application
we call this east west
so if you have a microservices-based
application here
and each of those microservices are
deployed
in containers
they're all
communicating with each other via rest
apis
this is usually east-west traffic
so nginx brings traffic in
once that's
within the kubernetes cluster it's it's
within the application rather than the
load balancer
so
this is where a service mesh might come
into play
but it does depend on the application
oftentimes the ingress controller can do
everything you need to do
but let's say you wanted to have mutual
dns
security between
all of the the application traffic
within kubernetes let's say you wanted
to limit
traffic from microservice 1 to
microservice 2.
very very granular requirements we're
talking about here
but that is
why you would start looking at something
like a service mesh
and
you would use a sidecar proxy for those
scenarios
so
let's simplify it
you have your layer several layer 7
ingress controller
traffic enters the cluster via the
ingress controller this entire layer 7
traffic comes in
when traffic passes from the ingress
controller to the service
and from the service to the pods
it's there three therefore
so this could be okay if your
application is simple and you don't have
the requirements for encryption perhaps
but
adding a service mesh here
would
give you the ability to manage east-west
traffic
so this could be
each will t less between your pods
it could be for better granularity like
open tracing and you want to see traffic
communicating within each microservice
it could be for devops methodologies or
things like a b testing
canary and blue green upgrades perhaps
you might decide to do some rate
limiting between your cause there are
many reasons why you would do this
the biggest reason is oftentimes
encryption encrypting traffic within the
cluster
so some of the use cases
of a service mesh very briefly
it's important to understand that
a service mesh only solves a very
particular set of problems like i
mentioned
these are not required these types of
features then you may be moving too fast
if you need mutual tls or client-side
authentication between
services within kubernetes
from the ingress to the egress or
east-west traffic
and maybe a service service mesh might
help you
if you need advanced load balancing like
traffic splitting and a b testing and
access control within your cluster
that could be a use case also
um
open source tooling prometheus for fana
all those things
perhaps you want to
view
metrics and analytics on the traffic
patterns you see in your cluster that is
something you could do with a service
mesh
often times
you don't need a service mesh and once
traffic hits your ingress controller and
ingress distributed to across
your individual application pods and
that is all you need
so you should ask yourself
you know if you could say yes to these
these items here
you'd probably
if you could say yesterday's and maybe
you could benefit from a service mesh if
not
maybe not yet
it's a very complex technology
we're not trying to scare you away from
this
we are seeing a lot of companies trying
to adopt a service mesh before they need
one and it causes a lot of complexity
and headaches if you've only started
using kubernetes then maybe a service
mesh isn't needed yet if you have
deployed an ingress controller and it
works very well to deliver your
applications then maybe you don't need
one yet but if you can
if you have a fully automated crc
pipeline you're using kubernetes you
have an ingress controller deployed you
want to add
visual tls to a zero trust environment
you want really granular traffic control
within your cluster then yes a service
mesh could definitely help you there
and the idea is that you inject a
sidecar proxy within your kubernetes
environment
to
to have more granular control in your
environment
so let's have a quick review of what we
learned today
so microservices is
not a destination
there will be different clouds
you might adopt microservices on-prem
you might use different tooling
the number of
tools in the industry is extremely high
automation tools like chef ansible
puppet
cloud platforms zero gcp aws
load balancing tools and ingress
controllers engine x five pha proxy the
list goes on and on we have multiple
devops tools
ci tools like jenkins
a devops platform like gitlab and and so
on
so there's actually a periodic table of
devops tools out there that's worth
looking at
but you will see
devops methodologies you will look at
api management solutions you will
certainly come across
kubernetes but it will take time and
it's too risky and expensive to move too
fast
we spoke about service mesh and ingress
controllers primarily because
they are key
to production-ready microservices
because the ability to control how
traffic reaches your applications or
microservices applications is very
important that's the where the data
plane lies
so uh tools like nginx and other ingress
controllers have a very important role
to play there also
okay that is the end of the presentation
let's have a quick look at the q a
okay
so question here both marlettes and
microservices have their pros and cons
do you think that marlettes will
completely disappear in the future
or would the number of them just shrink
that's a great question and the answer
is i'm not sure
because
when it comes to
all the applications i've worked with
it's
the monolith isn't going away anytime
soon
and oftentimes some of the most modern
applications you see out there today are
built around
microservices but some of the core
components are still monitored i do
think they will shrink
personally
but not anytime soon i think some actual
some applications are actually perfectly
fine to be a monolith that's important
to understand that too
my previous slide that went through some
of the cons of of moving to
microservices all those are relevant
and
things like complexity having multiple
containers for each of your application
performance that may not be needed if
you have a very simple application that
does one job
for example let's say you have
an online blog
and
essentially contains articles blog posts
and images
and it's pretty static and you add
updates
not too often then
a three-tier application monolith would
be absolutely perfect for that
database
clients server-side application
and a client side front end
okay
yes there's a comment here on top of
kubernetes concerns security is most
scary
yeah and that's a good point because
when it comes to security
it's
you hear things like zero trust you hear
things like service mesh reach with tls
between your application containers and
what we're seeing a lot more is the
ability to deploy a web application
firewall inside kubernetes
um
i know at nginx we do have the ability
to deploy
a web application firewall
on the ingress controller itself there
are multiple ways you could add security
to the kubernetes platform you could put
security outside on your on the
the external load balancer bringing
traffic into kubernetes
you could bring
security to the ingress controller as i
mentioned
you can start encrypting all the traffic
within kubernetes that no traffic can be
accessed without some encryption
that's a lot of ways to do it
but yeah we're seeing a lot of companies
adopt a zero trust model
are microservices a viable option for
small teams or individual application
developers
yeah so i think my answer to the
previous question answered that also
some applications are perfectly fine
to be a monolith
you can deploy an application using
microsoft microservice methodologies
also but if the application is is small
and it's
it doesn't it doesn't need to be scaled
horizontally then you don't you might
not necessarily need a microservices
environment but
it depends on how you want to deploy it
also because
if you
want to deploy things in kubernetes or
if you want to deploy things in
containers then obviously you want to
use a more lightweight
language
modern languages like node.js and
python for example are much more
container
friendly okay what essentially is the
difference between
an ingress controller
and a service mesh like istio
it's a good question there is confusion
around the two
and oftentimes we see
people mixing them up actually because
an ingress controller the idea is that
it brings traffic in
um it's layer seven it's a http load
balancer bringing traffic into your
kubernetes cluster and it works the same
way as as an nginx server sitting
outside
or inside and it does your tls
termination your load balancing and so
on and so forth but it focuses more on
north south traffic bringing traffic in
whereas a service mesh focuses more on
east-west traffic which is traffic
that's been distributed inside the
cluster
so you might have an ingress bringing
traffic into a microservice that
microservice might send requests to
another microservice
the ingress has no visibility of that
microservice 1 to microservice 2 request
with a service mesh you could add
another proxy within that layer 2 to to
keep track of that those traffic
patterns to add encryption to those
traffic patterns and a lot more than
that
so ingress north south service mesh east
west within kubernetes
okay i'm just browsing through the
questions here
yes there's a question here for a
networking world big ip
is used for load balancing
can enginex be a substitute big-ip
yeah a good question it's i think
they're both
slightly different in terms of how you
want to deploy them you know if
yes both solutions can do load balancing
um
nginx i often think is more associated
with the application
so it's closer to the application
whereas big-ip
is usually more of the network entry
point into your application portfolio
and in the previous example where we had
a dns service bringing traffic into an
ingress controller
we actually use both of them side by
side
big-ip could be used as your external
load balancer you can add a security
layer to that also
and then that's managed by the net ops
teams
and you could also
have an nginx ingress controller on
nginx proxy that's managed by the
application teams doing different things
like json web token authentication
or more more
layer 7
features i suppose
but it depends on the environment you
could use big-ip by itself
uh you could use engine expo itself
depending on what you need
okay there's a really good question here
about
what are different use cases for using
ingress controller versus ingress
gateway
that's a really good point because
kubernetes is adopting
a new type of
resource called
gateway
and
yeah so when you configure an ingress
controller you
you can configure an ingress resource in
kubernetes
and that is a manifest file
that is uh that's that is sent to the
kubernetes api
and that configures the load balancer
with the new gateway resource for
kubernetes it's a different
way of configuring
the load balancer rather than using
ingress resource you use the gateway
object
and there are plans to add that
to to nginx and other ingress
controllers out there
what are the benefits what is the
different use cases
i would say
the ingress
controller
if you write an ingress resource in
kubernetes oftentimes
they're the same regardless of what
ingress controller they're using
some ingress controllers have more
features than others
and in order to do those extra features
let's say for example a waf
policy or
or mutual tls for example you might need
to add an annotation in kubernetes to
extend the functionality whereas i think
an ingress gateway
would be
would allow for more custom or more
advanced use cases like that
is it mandatory to use an ingress
controller in kubernetes
technically no
it's not mandatory
but it's it's recommended
and if
so within kubernetes if you deploy an
application container
that container is running
within the internal kubernetes network
and there is no way to access
the container externally
unless you configure a way to get access
to it
and within kubernetes
how you do that is via a service
you create a service within kubernetes
and that allows you to expose
your application container that's
running within that pod network
if you expose your application container
within the pod network then
you are directly exposing your app with
no
that that proxy can be okay depending on
the application
but let's say you have
multiple applications for your
kubernetes which is the whole point of
having a kubernetes cluster it's to
allow microservices and apps to be
spread across multiple nodes
you don't want to be exposing
different
pod ip addresses from each application
to each microservice
you need to have
some form of entry point like an ingress
controller to bring traffic into the
into the application
that's one reason why
an inverse controller is recommended
it's to have
one load balancer to distribute traffic
to all of your pods
second of all
you most likely have a dns service
for the
the application
so
when a request comes into your website's
dns name
the ingress controller is responsible
for resolving that and sending that
request to
the relevant application that matches
the fqdn
that is something that would be a lot
more difficult with without an ingress
so i would say
i wouldn't recommend it but it can be
done if you have a single application
that runs as a single container
that has a built-in
tls termination then maybe you can just
expose it directly without an ingress
but of course that does depend on
what you're trying to achieve
what makes a language container friendly
yeah that's a good question um
i think
i don't think i have an answer to that i
think it depends exactly entirely on
the dependencies of an application you
know if
you're looking at a traditional
application it's
it most likely has an external database
it might have
external dependencies
for the server side
there might be an app server you know it
can be
it can be quite difficult to
containerize
something like that
and
you know
when it comes to having a database
within a kubernetes environment then
it kind of it's difficult to to have a
database within a container and scale it
horizontally
containers are meant to be stateless
whereas
a database isn't really stateless so i
think for something to be container
friendly it needs to be able to be
destroyed and spun up again without
losing data
it needs to be lightweight so some
traditional applications aren't
lightweight they're they might require
lots of libraries and dependencies and
they just don't fit well in a container
because they're too heavy
um you know if a container is over a
gigabyte in size then that might not be
very container friendly depending on the
app
but it's a very good question it's it's
it's a broad discussion but the first
two examples i thought of i suppose is
they're supposed to be stateless
and
the dependencies in the libraries need
to be lightweight
okay christina i think that's all we
have time for today
thank you very much for your time
hopper was useful
and please if there are any questions
reach out to the
the contact page after the call
great well thank you so much to mihal
for his time today and thank you to all
the participants who joined us
as a reminder this recording will be on
the linux foundation youtube page later
today we hope you're able to join us for
future webinars have a wonderful day